[Music]
hello and welcome to sidetrek your
sci-fi tv and movie channel as i always
say i am joined today by the chat that
does our discord server hello
which there is a link for in the
description which you can go and join it
but hello matt or mr relics
hello
matt's fine
we were nearly late or we actually were
a little bit late because we were
chatting
yes
and then suddenly we realized we had 10
seconds but hey we're there we're there
so today we're going to have a bit of a
chat and we are going to play a bit of a
fantasy role play you could you get to
pretend you are brad wright today sir um
and
we can imagine what the hell we would
like to see from the stargate new series
when it comes
so first of all we thought we would play
a little game of
what main characters would you love to
see return
to stargate
matt as you're a welcome guest you can
you can throw in what who's the first
person you'd love to see
first person's tylc
i'd love to have him back just just
i don't know
he was always my favorite from sg-1
i don't know why it's just that indeed
it's my favorite cat's phrase i always
say it
i'd love to have him back
i'll randomly say that people don't know
i've always had a good guy now but
i'm the manager of my day job and every
so often if somebody'll say something
stupid i just go
indeed
i'm going
i've got him on my um
on my noticeboard i can't say it
i've got a thing but yeah he's always
been my favorite
so he would be my first pick if if i if
i was in charge and they said who would
you want back
instantly talk
yeah
i think it was um
he was a brilliant straight man for a
lot of the comedy you know they would
make references to things but then as he
grew as well he actually
became a bit of a comedian as well you
know his is but um i think particularly
in the first two series which i think
the first two series made stargate
his emotional dilemma between
his past and working with the towery and
um you know and the guilt of what he'd
done as you know as um
as as apophis's prime was i think that
drove a lot of the show you know it gave
us a lot of um
a lot of story to tell so yeah
like i always like the stories where he
kind of got turned back to be in the
first prime when he got brainwashed
again i always loved those stories
or the alternate earth stories where
he he was the uh the one leading the
lead in the fight to the
to earth
yeah i think that with with with daniel
um was one of the first
really great episodes of stargate i mean
like properly
like um
that it's not just good stuff it's good
it's just
great television sort of thing you know
it's like um that mirror universe
episode was one of the ones that really
like
stands out
uh
the finale of season one
yeah yeah um just i mean oh you can't
you can't argue with it really that it's
i mean and there was there was two or
three really great episodes in the first
series i'm doing a look at the second
series at the moment looking at the
brilliant episodes from that and i'll
tell you what the second series
there's there's four or five episodes in
that series that are just like
whoa you know it's just like this is
this isn't just great sci-fi this is
just great television full stop this is
this is you know
am i trying to get i'm currently
watching season two again
and um
the one i've just watched i think it was
a couple of days ago it's thor's chariot
that's probably my favorite from that
secret from that series
spoiler for the video at the moment
thor's chariot is winning
if i'm going to say it's the best
episode of that series it might be
thor's character and i just watched it
again as well
and it's a brilliant episode it really
will
um
i'm with dragonfly i would love to see
jack come back
but he is a man in his 70s
so
um i i think the obvious
obvious thing here is and we know from
brad wright that excuse me he's thinking
about
amanda tapping coming back generally
directing and doing other things but
general carter he's mentioned it a
couple of times
and i should be to see general carter
married to jack and that would be a way
for jack to like pop in for the other
episode here and there just you know say
hello
and you know have a quip crack a joke
good morning rappers
and then um you know like take a piss
out of somebody and then leave
yeah i think that'd be great you know
um
that's a good point i hadn't thought
about that ian
walter does have to be in it doesn't he
doesn't he
yes yeah i have to have water
um
i actually did a video on this ages ago
and somebody asked me where would walter
be would it be funny if walter was like
um in command now and he was like this
will come back and i think now i think
it'd be funny please just do the same
thing
i think everybody goes chevron one and i
i think that would be hilarious if you
just um just turned up because they mean
they did take the piss out of that in a
few few videos anyone they did like you
know they did the interview one where
they they're all getting interviewed and
he said so what do you actually do
there's all like i kind of say chef from
one coated
and that's and that's about it
i like the episode as well where
um
this i
can't remember the actual plot i'm
pretty sure it's something to do with
the issue um
but anyway the the stargate was like a
museum and he was it was still its
target command
it was just like the
the tour guide or something
going to jump in guys get into the
comments and say hey john
throw us our names here john carl says
hello
rodney i said to you at the start we can
have fantasy pick here now you can you
can pick anybody
but then you've got to have a bit of
realism who would actually come back
um and i think um
i judge with you really to know that i
think if you didn't invite invite david
hewlett he would turn up anyway and just
start appearing in the background and
reading stuff and i mean it's
i love um on his twitter when he
released that john lewis he did the
front page of the stargate something
serious and he wrote in stargate mckay i
mean that's just that is his sense of
humor and
you know i watch him on twitter a lot
and he's mad as a bag of frogs
he's got to come back and he
yeah
i'd love
yeah like i was saying to you before
because he is
so involved in stargate i i can't see
any reason why he would never come back
if
i don't think they'd even have to ask
him i think he would volunteer
yeah you know i think he's actually
probably stalking brad wright as we
speak he's probably out he's now he's
just waiting for he's in his head
just let me know just let me know yeah
yeah yeah constant pms any news
um
and yeah i think he'd be great he was
always one of the first ones whenever
they did the um
like behind the scenes videos and things
he he did loads of those back in the day
and he was again he was always hilarious
um
he's not right but he is hilarious
how do you feel about then somebody
outside of sg-1
i mean i know mckay was sgsg outside of
sg1
um
ronan i'd like to see ronan back
yeah probably would never happen but i
would love to fantasy pick definitely a
fantasy pick i think yeah
um
i kind of want to see we're back but
she's still alive
not the actress i mean the character
did she die
technically
yes but then she also didn't because
there was a clone of her
i see this tv
jacket died and then he came back so
that was a stupid episode
i think that was voted the most hated
episode in all of stargate history
rebecca and people went ballistic
um but yeah
um i'd love to see and and somebody had
his jumped in louis good evening sir um
yeah shepard i think he was a great he
and he is somebody's well true fine
against somebody as well that really
pushed
to get stargate to come back didn't he
even try to buy the right switch or
something
um
um
it's nice
um
it
and i can hear myself
yeah that's a very good explanation
a description sorry
any better
oh mal's better yeah i've switched to
the laptop
uh then my very expensive two or three
hundred pound microphone piece of crap
um
[Music]
um
shepard
yeah
um i just think he's a likeable actor as
well that's and that's one of the things
he like but also he's not a dream pick
because he would be back in a second
ronan was always my favorite stargate
atlantis character i loved ronan as soon
as he left i knew he was going to be a
massive movie star because he's just
he's just fantastic
but
they would
say you might squeeze him back for an
episode because he also does seem like
one of those actors that um jason momoa
that it doesn't say no to anything
um so you might get him to come back for
an episode but you'd never get him to
come back
no
no no no but uh
i'm trying to think who else i'd love to
see i think teal i think the general car
thing i think we're going to see daniel
jackson but what role
if if you wanted general daniel jackson
in what role would you want to see me
i think he'd be um
some sort of like like a consultant kind
of role
he'd have to be involved in some way
because
really daniel jackson is the entire
reason the stargate program exists
yeah
and it does have to be involved in some
way yeah it does look like it get he's
going to and they're talking about
directing
uh
potentially as well so behind the camera
as well um obviously he is on the
companion
thing with them with brad right that he
does
um so
but i think
it would be good daniel jackson's left
the blacklist
um
i used to love the blacklist it's i just
stopped watching after about the third
season but yeah he was like that i think
it'd be good because you know i said um
apparently the gay program is now public
everybody knows about it
so
civilian leader
he's the you know he's actually the boss
yeah that's a good i think that could
work i could yeah and then he wouldn't
be day in day out
in the series so he could then direct
and do behind the screen stuff but he's
like
then yeah because it wouldn't be a
military leader if if it's out there and
everybody knows about the program
they're not gonna allow be allowed to
have a military leader i don't think
that that big public outcry something
that
you know it would it would be
interesting to see him in in charge
because he brought a lot of empathy to
the team
like with with any of the stories he was
usually the voice of reason
so i think
that would actually be quite a good idea
if he was a leader or if he was like
um
involved in
if the ioa still exists
something to do with that
uh like maybe
maybe replace woolsey
yeah like a civilian oversight committee
sort of thing
and um and like you said like um
consultant
i'm not 100
sure his character would go for that
though
that's what you have to do you have to
think about what the character would
want to do yeah because i'm i don't
think
jackson had
um
very good thoughts about the ioa just
because of how how many times they tried
to burn the sgc
which was yeah which was
repeated um
cassandra that's a good remember it's
targeting panther pickle yeah she's
almost
oh well there you go
we saw we saw old cassandra in
was it
1969 the episode is it yeah that episode
uh and we've obviously seen young
cassandra we've never seen her as an
adult so it'd be interesting to see what
she's like
yeah there's i i i think there would be
a few characters that could come back as
well like like cassandra um jackson
that storyline the um thing that the you
know he's the the clone the clone sorry
he's out there and about um i said i i
said
we saw a few young sg
team members at times that came in and
out we could see again
i said to you guys i've been writing
some fan fiction and i've got one
character that was in it and she's the
commander of the hammonds now and i
can't remember a freaking name it's been
so long since i've been able to write
the damn thing because of work work
really does get in the way of my fun
um i really wish i didn't have to guys
if you could all just
pay me to do this that would be much
better um and then hit that join button
yeah hit that join button please yeah if
you if a thousand of you do that i can i
can quick
i can just do this every day
um but um
everybody watching right now did
trying to get my wife to agree to it um
i tell you what somebody has just thrown
in a name that you're going to enjoy
because you've already mentioned him
earlier but
there are lots of characters like that
that could come in um because we've had
10 years
you know if sg-1
um
you know so
but here we go
i thought he was dead
i thought he was dead
um
but um yeah he was he was one of those
um i tell you what it's actually or is
it
um samantha's dad that's dead
yeah he died yeah he's i think that's
who i was thinking so um the actor i
mean
i can't think of his name in real life
but he died in the series as well so
yeah so um
but but yeah i'd love to see braytack
back and i said i joked to the early
know i said that he's he's got
wicked evil eyes you know like but in
like he's got naughty he's got really
good naughty eyes and i think that guy
could do anything he could go give his
20 quid and he just would
you know because he's like that you you
cheeky little bugger he's totally quick
uh you know i'm saying um i i i
suggested something different to that
earlier but i'm not sure i should say it
i wasn't gonna say i thought you said
earlier
someone just said in the comments are
the tolling's alive
i have a theory that one of them a few
of them did survive so having
having some of them come back um what
was his name
uh the guy who the actor ended up
marrying where
in sg atlantis what's his name noreen
miriam his name
yeah i'd love to see him come back
i i think that would be i think the
tournament should be an interesting
storyline as well because there's so
much you can do with that particularly
with the science and everything else
well
my my fantasy episode of that would be
they've they obviously all got wiped out
most of them like they say 90 got wiped
out but a few of them managed to get
through to stargate so yeah some would
escape yeah definitely so you've got a
colony they're not as advanced as they
once were but they're still pretty smart
and they would still have yeah advanced
technology so they'd have something so
whatever they went out with
and i think i think that would be really
interesting
yeah way of of um because that's that's
one thing with what we've got now is
that the stargate team
is or stargate command has got advanced
seriously advanced technology and i
actually did a video about long ago
about how there's a real danger brad
wright's gonna have to be really clever
um
yeah i want to see claudia black come
back just because i really like what she
used to wear
i was just like
i never had a leather fetish until
claudia black turned up i'm like i think
i'm developing one
um but i'm joking
never as a car warrior look so good
oh yeah oh she was yeah
he sits on her lap and he's like oh
jesus
and she was just so funny they were so
good together they bounced off each
other so well they were brilliant
um
i'd like to see them together if
yeah if if he comes back like maybe just
mention her even if she doesn't want to
come back
yeah yeah i think she probably would the
um
her and i forgot his name here i know
his real name
the chapter came in for season nine and
ten it was on um
oh cam mitchell camp mitch yeah i'd like
to see him come back as well because i
love that one scene
one of the things i'm talking about is
um i'm doing a video at the moment so
i'm gonna spoil but
the humor of star game when daniel
jackson and camera stood next to each
other and they kind of look alike
and um claudia black's guy just comes up
says
shallow gene pool here
yeah
that's just such a clever joke you know
most people
yeah ben browder thank you um thread
book and soil
um but yeah ben brown uh and he he's
still been he's in the marvel gardens
the galaxy too
he he appeared a little part in that he
was one of the gold dudes
and so uh when he's telling the gold
woman he's like the general
so the gold ones like all the drawing
drones had been destroyed and going to
the galaxy yeah i remember old dude
um
i'm always looking for these things
right but yeah but yeah he appears in
things that were softer so he'd probably
do it and i like the camera it's always
fun seeing stargate characters in other
shows like i don't know if you've seen
the mandalorian i have but
um camille ray is in mandalorian and
she's also in bob affair
yep yeah no she's great
um
oh i've gotten a name there
i did a video with my mate last week um
with stormy regulars the sidetrack you
know and we were talking about old films
in a rubbish we talked about um street
fighter
and um nina i want to say nina
what's that name
the
the main woman from mandalorian
who's in her 50s
for god's sake right anyway i'm sure
that i'm sure that's camille ray isn't
it
yeah well she's in star trek she's in
street fighter which is nearly 20 years
old and she looks exactly the same
um but anyway so um i lost my train i
thought where were we
um
i tell you what we'll talk about because
it keeps stopping popping up and then i
want to talk about what do people
actually want the storyline to be so
we've talked about characters and
returning characters and there's loads
of them and i want to see a load of new
characters as well
but the villain
some brilliant villains
over the years would we want to see any
of them come back because the wraith
story was never actually concluded
they're still knocking about
being being all vampire vampirey
with their hands
um the replicators still never actually
got totally wiped out i don't think
um even though they did once or twice
but then they always seem to come back
i think they don't get totally worked
out they didn't tell me why didn't they
because they know they used the and
thinking because of the stargate like
big wave thing um they use the the car
yeah
so with that they're gone um it doesn't
mean that they can still have them from
other galaxy circus that only affected
the milky way
exactly we've i always wondered whether
anubis could come back
because
he doesn't die
he ascends
and then um
omar basically goes into an eternal
battle with him
um
but that doesn't mean he's dead and he
was always my favorite bad guy i
actually think um
i i did a video about the worst villain
and he topped my list
because he actually nearly wiped all
life out
of the universe he came that close to
wiping it all out
um
i think he could definitely come back
yeah if there was a storyline that
somehow affected the ancients
which made it so oma had to stop
fighting him he could then become a
secondary
uh villain
which is still quite a powerful villain
because he's he's half ascended but
yeah i think that could work
i'd love to see him back i did like he
was my favorite jennifer haley is the
woman i was trying to think of earlier
that she's in my um in my story she's
the most
she's there
yeah she now commands the hammond in my
story that i'm trying to write and yeah
as soon as i can quit my job
if you would like to join the channel
please do
um as soon as i can quit my job i'm i'm
going to write that
i like this though juice bowl it's good
let's just have them all back
we're all cool everybody just pretend
like the last 10 years didn't happen
yeah yeah it's great
um
but i like the idea of i like the idea
of news you know the one villain that
i'm not convinced by and i think would
be a bit boring is the lucian alliance
i i didn't know that i don't think
they're involved
with our new weapons now they could come
with us with as many attacks as they
liked and we'd
you know be like it'd be complete it'd
be a turkey shooter they'd have to come
back unless they got hold of anubis
shields or something they they need to
be wiped out
yeah well i mean the
the asgard tech that we had
like could destroy an all-right ship and
it did at least once
attacks are nowhere near it as advanced
so
the only threat they they only posed a
threat to destiny
and that was a good storyline
to the actual like milky way atlantis
whatever they're not gonna
be good enough in my opinion
i would love to see adria come back
because i think she's generally as the
queen of sci-fi
um and i love doing with firefly and i'm
not going to try and say her name she's
quite hard to say um but she is
gorgeous
i love her very much
did she not die
not really she kind of got
um is she the same as a as a newbie yeah
she's kind of just like lost all her
power didn't she so i think
but um she went into into battle didn't
she with
who was it
another ascended being
can't remember her name
that's what i think as well so
yeah i mean like a lot of things saying
love to see actually
finish the james center that would have
to feed on humans that would be good
he's actually
irritates race
good name
come back
do you think we're going to get new
villains or i think we'll brad wright
would bring back
some of the old villains but he's got to
come up with something new isn't he for
the new series
yeah i'm not convinced that the
uh the grow older uh
are done with because
by the time a ball uh in continuum was
just was like killed or whatever
it was only the system lords that they
were targeting really they're still
lower goals that exist like
they've got they are on the reality
i i think that the goal i i don't know
if the gold would come back as the main
antagonist for a show but i'd love to
see him come back
at some point
um somebody had an idea of um a gold and
a wraith merge
and come back
marina baccarin thank you that's her
name she's beautiful i love her very
much
um
if you're holding the
yeah that would be quite interesting
that would be
kind of like when they were with the
unass but
yeah that's the type of thing they were
going with i think
get him and get wraith again i'm sorry
gotta go old into the biggest baddest
body you can think
um
and then then see
then you know watch him go crazy sort of
thing but um
one storyline i do
is
that i do want answered
is the fearlings ever loads of people
have mentioned it already is the third
things we only we only ever saw
one thing from the firlins two things if
you count 200 episodes but we're not
going to count that
um
yeah it's it's heavily implied that
that's the furlings
but we have no actual comp like um
confirmation
yeah exactly we um
it's suspected that the weather planet
the weather machine on that one planet
was potentially
um furling technology and the
summit stone what's it called the thingy
stone that was supposed to be
their technology but we never had it
confirmed
star
uh some touchstone or turning valve i
forget anyway it's too much stuff in it
but the paradise lost episode
that was a furling um supposed to be a
um
[Music]
a utopian planet where the furlings
lived and they were coming and a gold
snooker
plant on it then they made them go
paranoid and kill each other
um
so but we only yeah we never
they're the only species out of the four
of the alliance that we've actually
didn't get to know well to be fair that
we never really got to know the knox
that well
they were always very isolate
an isolated
society when they didn't really want to
be
involved with anyone no no that's not
the totallands
yeah i love you ian but if brad wright
does a time channel episode i'm blaming
you
so um
well to go back in time and make a
sudden show was never cancelled
that would be lovely
well i heard basically i was told that
the timekeepers game is going to tell us
a lot about where stargate is going to
go in the future because amazon would
like to interlock all these things
they'd like the game to influence the cv
series and rubber um marvel style
um so i think the game and the game is a
time travel thing it's backwards and
forwards through time
um and we know the gate can be used to
time travel
but if they and let's be honest star
trek love that sort of thing and amazon
or mgm might look at what star trek are
doing are thinking oh let's do something
along those lines but if they do
i might have to punch
somebody in the in the go dads because i
mean it'll just be [ __ ]
um look at discovery
you know it's just it's just not good
and as soon as you start doing time
travel that's when canon gets the crap
kicked out of it in my opinion and i
just think if if you do it time travel
episodes if they're doing well are great
but how many times have they done well
most the time they're done really badly
um and somebody ends up impregnating
their grandma or something and it's just
like no don't do it
um
the giant aliens and daniel's grandpa we
could see those come back
theme something with me with the
feelings though it was my thought was we
need a new bad guy we know so little
about the
could they be the antagonist could they
come back and be the bad guy
that that would be quite quite cool
it's interesting i was thinking that
um
when i was thinking of potential
storylines that they
ended up being the bad guy of a new
series
but also
um we kind of had a taste of it in
atlantis but you know the the evil
asgard
yeah
having them be an antagonist
like a proper threat this time rather
than just like kidnapping daniel and
rodney
i i think that would be great actually i
don't know if that again is a serious
antagonist but as a double episode or
something
um
i i want the asgard to come back
yeah in some way
that would be cool again because you
could do a similar thing like with the
feelings or the evil asgard something
they come back and you think they're on
your side and that could you know that
could develop and they turn between but
i was thinking about either that as well
i think they'll i hope they don't do
this in a way but all
villains on a lot of shows now that have
been copying marvel
where the villain um is that that thanos
question isn't it was is thanos really a
villain because he doesn't think so he
thinks he's the good guy
um and you could argue he's right
um you know so and i think they'll do
something like that with stargate that's
what i i suspect
um
they'll do a villain that is
um
you know that you can see their point
they can see the side of things you can
you know
excuse me obviously what they're doing
is
evil but they're not evil just for the
sake of being evil you know bad guys
have got to have a lot more depth
nowadays haven't they
um
so
that's what i always liked about baal
he was evil but he
was he had
more to him than just being evil
like apophis
was just evil
yeah
he was a great great protag uh
protagonist is a protagonist
um but baal was always always my
favorite gold other than animus
um for
the fact that it was so much
more to him
one of my favorite scenes with balls
there waiting i know neil walks up on us
because he's like i've been waiting here
because i was having a lovely brunch
oh here he goes insolence and he goes no
tuna
so good so good
i should do a video one of the days so
just go right
tell us all your favorite bits go watch
this
um
parallel universes and things like don't
do it don't do it oh no don't use
parallel universes
that's a trope that's used a lot to
solve a lot of issues and i don't think
that's it's lazy
yeah
you know
the thing with the um ferlins
because they were part of the four great
races they were essentially a
democracy of all these these
species if they're still alive they
could come back
as
envoys of this long-lost
democracy yeah they look at the way the
state of the galaxy is now and then be
like we we don't like how it is so
they're technically the villain but
they've got a reason why
that's that's where i'm going with it i
was thinking about sort of um babylon
five
and the um
[Laughter]
fallen the vollens have you ever watched
babylon 5 because you're um no
i've got so many so many times my shows
i've got to watch
babylon 5 is amazing in that um yeah
they've got these ball ons that are like
um
there's some cheesy bits in it that
they're like angels and stuff in at one
point but you know that but all the way
through there's this battle against the
shadows and you think the shadows are
the villains all the way through and the
vorlands are here to protect us
and then at the battle in the end the
the vaulons basically decide that the
best way to wipe out the shadows is to
wipe out everybody
um and so they they turn on everyone
um
and so then the volumes and the shadows
are fighting and everyone else is
fighting and so they um basically the
shadows have got all these like secret
alliances and things with all the
different worlds
and you know like i think so they just
have all this just wipe out everybody
that the shadows have ever touched but
the shadows have touched everyone so
it's like um they were they were touches
um so yeah you could have that sort of
thing where they come back and they go
you're so corrupt and everything has
gone so sideways that the only way to
you know we need to add order to the
galaxy is to like wipe all you out or or
just to say well you're not like you're
not allowed to start getting well we're
going to take them away
something or something like that um
there's there's lots of ways they could
do that which would be really really
interesting
um
so
that's our minds could be uploaded in
the asgard law they said all knowledge
is in there what if they meant literally
they could ask the pegasus to clone some
bodies for their comrades
i don't that that i don't think that um
that would work because they
they couldn't solve the the cloning
issue
otherwise they wouldn't even needed to
blow themselves up but that's like start
again and then yeah but they they were
copies of copies of copies and they were
slowly deteriorating but um
but let's say that they are
their minds still there somewhere so
they i think there are ways the the
actual asgard could come back but i like
your idea about the the evil asgard or
asgard from outside the galaxy coming
back or something because i mean they
should be everywhere
yeah there's lots of ways there's loads
of different colonies
something
that i was uh interested in seeing and
this is this is based on if they do a
prequel series you know for
the ancients
is seeing the the star of the four great
races and seeing the asgard in their
true form
so after we saw
we kind of saw the asgard in that that
um that chamber
but obviously it wasn't walking and
talking and interacting i'd like to see
that
that'd be cool i i think that's a really
good idea um
i i think the um
yeah
i i like the idea of doing a prequel
series because normally i hate prequels
and again that's going trekkie
because as soon as star trek started in
prequel series i don't know why they
keep insisting in star trek
to remake this to do the same story over
and over again
um but anyway um i don't want them to do
that with stargate but the thing is with
stargate it's different we've literally
got millions of years worth of history
i'd love to see the plague
you know where they ended up building
the weapon under car in the first place
and um you know and and how that
happened i'd love to see how the ori and
the ancient split happened in the first
place i think that would be really
interesting
um
there's so many stories you know that we
got little
glimpses off at times but instead of
like destroying cannon they could add so
much
because we could actually get some
storage but also there's millions and
millions of years they could do it
really easily without
as long as they weren't thick about it
as long as they didn't say
again do like a discovery and like oh
we've just got this
ship that is far more powerful than
anything we're supposed to have this
time you know as long as they're
thinking about it
um
they could do it kind of like
uh
because obviously like i said there's
millions of years of um events that
would have happened that we haven't seen
a prequel series could have could be
like let's say a hundred
i'll say a.d but
when i say 80 i mean before
millions of years ago
um
where something happens and then they
have a little a little bit of a a nice
little lull and then 380 the next
storyline could take place
we can see them advancing
as it goes but we don't have to like sit
through millions of episodes
for them
it's
like we see them slowly progress
absolutely the point that we knew
when they ascended
i think the yeah and the essentially the
ascension happened in stages as well so
i mean that's that that's interesting
but um that's the thing that's with
streaming services the way it is
nowadays instead of um you know like
old-fashioned tv shows where you have to
have series like that streaming
they can do little ten episode hits
because you they do it like they set it
up like a they film it like a movie but
they release it in you know six or seven
that mini series something
um
there's no reason why they couldn't have
an ancient series where you have 10
episodes
of one bit and then have completely new
actors 10 episodes another story and you
know like so that's one of the benefits
of streaming that they could do that
no bother all
um
i'd love to see someone do it i mean
they're talking about this for the new
battlestar galactica the the creator of
the balsa galactic sort of said we don't
have to release
episodes
like that anymore we can release
episodes in any way we like
you know so we can do it we can do these
three episodes sit together really
nicely so let's release them all in one
go let's read them the same day and this
you know there's lots of things they can
do and in streaming services they can do
something similar to the ancients
we could have just whole episodes
we could just have a mini episode
halfway through a series of an ancient
flashback or something as well and
things like that there's lots of things
they could do
um
i think i think one storyline that most
people
would would want
is a conclusion to the universe
let's talk about university
i didn't hear about it i've done a video
my last video go back and have a look
please guys
target universe could we save eli
yes bradley says
he's basically hinted more than once
i saw a theory on on how they save eli
i thought i don't know if i don't if it
was part of like a comic or something
like that or if it was just a fan theory
but it was something to do with
um putting himself in a stargate buffer
coming out every
night month or i don't know what the
timeline was let's say
every year until they eventually get um
to a certain point
you know where they've stole that from
though didn't you
no
well not star trek the next generation
yet not yet
um there's an episode where um
um
oh [ __ ] sake
names going out my head again
the the engineer from star trek the
original series
miracles um anyway they find him i can't
believe his name's going out my head
john james doing i know he's i know the
actor's name and i think
please somebody tell me um anyway
we find him on a dyson sphere and they
find a shuttle um and um he has put
himself in the transporter in a buffer
so he basically is just in a transporter
cycle so like decades have gone by and
they just beam him out sort of thing so
they're completely scotty how do i
forget scotty
oh scotty yeah beat me up scotty
live videos trying to think about too
many things at once i'm trying to talk
to you and read comments and think about
what i'm going to say next
um yeah i've got an excuse not to know
everything already on episode 13.
yeah
scotty god's sake
um
but yeah 70 years apparently continuing
so that yeah that sounds like that's
stolen straight from that but hey that's
okay
yeah they steal
well it's like i was saying when i
when i started watching so i've started
watching star trek the original series
i've not seen snapchat before i've
watched it i've watched the movies you
know with um sacramento and stuff but
i've not seen the actual series
so i started watching it and i'm on that
the episode called menagerie and like i
was saying to you earlier
um
what's his name pike
in his wheelchair i was saying doctor
who obviously stole that um for that for
us
yeah this looks exactly the same
i think so yeah i think it's definitely
i love the little light
just like more scoping
um
can he start the engine's captain
but he's something to explain david
blue's weight loss well yeah
we were talking as well he
there's no food on the uh
[Laughter]
yeah
guys you're getting really stuck into
the comments today love it keep going
you could use that like this to send an
upload to the university chip to start
making
locked away somewhere around the destiny
yeah
there's a there's a villain that's been
on destiny all this time
why not in stasis somewhere
you know you look at comics the
engineers are all and and when they when
they release everyone from uni from the
destiny when they save them or they
inadvertently
release this entity as well that's
actually quite quite a good idea
you don't know what destiny could have
come in contact with in a million years
floating through
shooting through space could come in
contact with anything
yeah i like those blue aliens i want to
see them again
yeah
oh there's those fishy aliens as well
yeah
there's so much isn't that that i i i
think he's gonna say i think he's gonna
have to come up with a new villain
i i know
at one point they were thinking about
this it was gonna be roughly based on um
an old ancient aliens theory of the
anunnaki i don't think brad wright will
go anywhere near that
um
i think it's been done you know we did
the whole egyptian thing i think brad
white's got enough sense not to do that
again
um but there are lots of things in in
our history that we they could explore
you know greek myths and things that
they wanted to um but i think stargate
was moving away from that
anyway towards the end of the series
you know we we had the asgard and we had
things like that that you know obviously
from our mythology
but obviously the or i won't and that
was nothing to do that was completely
different idea so
yeah it was a dyson sphere
well so
what other villains do you think you
could think of is there anything you'd
like to see
so i said to go award haven't i um
and i'll tell you guys i got a question
for you then
from brad wright from the interviews and
things we've got we know he is thinking
about making the stargate it's so it'll
be public everybody will know about the
stargate program
and we've already said that maybe it'd
be interesting if daniel was like the
civilian leader of that program then or
something do you think that's a good
idea if you were brad wright would you
do that
or would you keep it a secret
and get in the comments as well guys you
tell me what you think as well
would you do that i
think from a storytelling perspective it
would be very good
because it's
completely different to what we're used
to it's not secret anymore
and having
having a big overarching threat
where the whole world knows about it and
it actually feels like a threat
would be good
in terms of story because there was
always
there was always world ending events in
stargate but no one else knew about them
having the whole world know about it
would create that sense of panic
and
like
devastation that could potentially
happen
mm-hmm
it would it would i think yeah from from
a story
it does have a different dimension to it
doesn't it that
it was like for me
the risk is
the point about stargate was that it
could be true
you know it could actually be happening
you know i love that old story that um
allegedly in cheyenne mountain there's a
broom cupboard and it's got stargate
commanding on it you know i don't know
if that's true or not but
know i didn't know actually there was
googling that recently that cheyenne
mountain isn't norad anymore um space
force is based out of there
space force all stargate command
command
so um space force go
um but yeah it does sound great stargate
doesn't at that space yeah
the logo is just like oh you [ __ ]
dicks i'm just like they've just taken
the stargate like one straight in the
light a star trek logo so just
straighten the lines up a little bit um
but but yeah i i think it's a risk
um
but the problem is they've gone so far
uh hell beaker you are later
they've gone so far that it's like
impossible not to i think brad wright is
sort of right in a way that we've got to
sort of make it public because it's
unbelievable that it wouldn't be
you know we've got spaceships flying
around forgot so we've got a fleet of
spaceships it's ridiculous but the risk
is
it becomes star trek
you know it's it's
it's different it's not stargate anymore
but you could argue that atlantis wasn't
it could be
it could work
um
just because it's public knowledge
doesn't mean it's public use
so
the actual day-to-day
could be very similar to what we're
already used to
it's just everyone on earth kind of
knows
um
but i think having
everyone on earth know could create more
threats as well which can create more
story because you'd have
obviously we've had things like the ioa
before
um but there could be like
other countries
um it could get like quite political
like with other countries like trying to
i don't know discredit america or
something i'm not i'm not writing a
story but something could happen well we
are writing the story that's the point
of this video
let's say russia then russia wants the
stargate back
did they have they still got their
stargate or did they get blown up
no they gave it us
didn't we use it to destroy
we lost ours and yeah we did yeah and
then we we rented it off those russians
yeah
i don't know if they do anything to do
with current actual real-life events but
that could be interesting for a story
yeah and that that's the problem is i
suppose
it's going to be it's going to be proper
science fiction now you know it's going
to be it can't be real anymore
you know that was a whole thing less you
when it could be real it could actually
be happening that's that's going to be
gone now but i think that probably i
think somebody mentioned earlier it's
already like star trek i think that
probably got to that point
where it was stupid it was just that it
was still a secret probably around
series five or six definitely when we
started having the prometheus and then
the deadliest and then then you start
thinking oh god this couldn't be a
secret anymore it's stupid so maybe it
is actually i think it's a risk but
maybe it's stupid not to
and we have to trust brad wright at the
end of the day
that he knows what he's doing
yeah i think it i think it will all
depend on
how it got discovered
whether it was new administration in
america just like yeah we're just gonna
make it public or whether it was
someone leaked the information
and then they had to they had to
acknowledge it
because they could either way can create
interesting stories
yeah
um that might be an interesting way to
start the series where is it like the
episode uh is it called disclosure
yeah
uh when they when they're bringing in
the new prime uh prime minister
president yeah
they do do filler episodes in stargate
but they did even better than a lot of
tv shows
normally i hate filler episodes but they
they those are usually pretty good
because they had a story attached to
them yeah yeah i like that we're not
we're not going to get that anymore with
filler episodes and things but
um
i'll tell you what i'm actually
struggling to keep up with the comments
guys you're doing amazing thank you so
much
um at the end there'll be two days back
in the technically so yeah good one one
in secret maybe um but i do think that
might be an interesting way to start the
series
is that something happens
and that is so
you know big they can't hide the program
anymore
um
i think that's a bit of a cliche but
well we've got allies so one of our
allies could just turn up or something
you know like um innocently
planned and i'm going to the tab because
the towering are everywhere you're known
throughout the universe and then but the
people don't know and it's like you know
it's like so it could just be that you
know a hack turns up
and yeah
in a friendly way and misses everything
so but i'd like to see that you know
something so massive happens that they
have to admit it and then then the first
few episodes could be like them
um you know them them finding the new
feat in this new thing because i think
if they just start that it's public
that's a lot of story than these not
told isn't it yeah it's just like well
that that's that's a worry i had if it
if it just starts and it's um in in the
video you describe it's like in this
tournament or ever
how did you get there
are they going to explain it or is it
going to be a throwaway comment
like yeah
i'd like to see it unravel
yeah that's that's that's the thing
isn't it it's such a big storyline they
can't just go well it is
unless they can't think of a
way to do it because it would change the
world wouldn't it though i mean this
would be like if aliens landed on the
white house tomorrow there's another
story what would how would the world
react to that how would the world not
only react to
that there are aliens the world has
nearly been destroyed several times
on a weekly basis sometimes since target
yeah it's like the world was saved every
saturday night at eight o'clock this
week um
and then they'll find out that the plate
that the the virus that happened from
the aura was actually an alien threat
it's a bit like if it happened in real
life us finally got coronavirus was
actually
from some distant galaxy
yeah we'd be
pissed
hence civilian leader
you know and someone like daniel but
that that that would require a massive
explanation so i hope that's kind of
what where he goes to that that's what i
think if i was brother i think that's
why i would start
um
like i do worry about it becomes star
trek but i also think
if you think about the start of sg1 to
where sg1 ended
and the technology we amassed by the end
of that 10 years
it's been 15 years now since
stargate sg1 ended
atlantis is sat in san francisco bay
we're gonna have to explain that one
yeah um
you know so we've we've got about 15
years or 10 years exploring atlantis
um and whatever technological so where
is that technology going to be that's my
point
yeah
you've got a
you've got to think that
we wouldn't have just stopped
that we got all the asgard tech
and as you said
atlanta
so we would have discovered some new
stuff
but how are they going to
show us
when that happened
yeah
it's going to be set now isn't it brad
wright said it's it's now it's not like
a continuation from back then it's it's
here and here and now yeah
they'd have to do some kind of
potentially flashbacks i guess
could do in stages doing some sort of
yeah do little which which again they
could do it's no it wouldn't be
difficult
um
it's a big problem
that a lot of time has gone by
um but i suppose that's an advantage as
well though isn't it that because
sometime has gone by
um
that it's almost it is like a reset in
lots of ways that there are lots of
things you can do now that you maybe
couldn't have done if we'd have gone
straight into another series
um
yeah so i i
i think it's a risk i think he's gonna
have to be very very clever
um but
from what we're seeing and what he's
saying um people are very excited about
script
that's been that's been written the
antagonist is again very exciting
apparently and um
i just hope he's not being maybe too
clever
sometimes i think tv writers trying to
do something different they can be they
can try to force it a little bit um and
then you end up just getting something
that's
different for the sake of it rather than
different
for the with a point
i hope brad wright is seasoned enough
though and gets a team around him as
well that he sees enough that he
wouldn't make that mistake
i think he i think he'd be
i i don't think that would be a risk
with brad
well because he's made other things
since and they've been
fantastic i don't know if you've seen
travelers i have you i love that show
that was
boring
did you
i watched the first half of the first
season
you need to finish it it's i did always
think about coming back i think actually
to be fair i thought it had been
cancelled because i think whatever i was
supposed to be on didn't pick it up
i think the first i i'm not sure about
the first season
i'm pretty sure it got cancelled but
then it got revived but now it's
cancelled after season three which is
really annoying
yeah um i i that's i think why i um
i stopped watching it because it got
cancelled and then and i didn't realize
it got picked up again until like the
third season came out and i thought
they'd cancel that
um
there's so many other great shows i did
like the premise of travelers i thought
the premise was really clever
i did like action and um and i loved the
main guy whose name's gonna make
um but anyway he's he's great um
oh for the guy from travelers yeah um
and then the will and grace will from
will and grace i think that's another
reason why i thought they'd been
canceled because when grace came back oh
cause i think that's why i probably
thought we'd been canceled but anyway
um
i love travelers but i couldn't finish
it because i didn't want it to end
so you just don't
just restart the series as soon as
season three ends watch season again i
just just keep doing that
when they cancel tv shows on them on
cliffhangers don't make that is the most
annoying thing on the planet yeah that
is i lie awake sometimes thinking about
a couple of series that vented on
cliffhangers there's a series called the
fog that no one watched
and that ended on him like a huge
cliffhanger but the final episode was
the most interesting episode of the
entire series it's on netflix still
um and i sometimes like him i wonder
what would have happened and it's like
it wasn't even that good just get out
your brain man
um
but i did it with um manifest they they
canceled that on a really big
cliffhanger yeah that that is coming
back though i've been told
that yeah there's gonna be one more
series this next year is gonna be the
final one
um but it's in i think it's filming yeah
i like the manifest
yeah
to make the story flow more easily like
the fact that many societies tend to
speak in english yeah yeah we just
ignore that though
i was speaking to someone about that the
other day
how do you feel
in in doctor who there's a there's a
logical reason you've got the tardis in
i've not obviously i've not sure started
but in stargate there's none of that
there's no logical reason but
the ultimate answer is we wouldn't
understand them otherwise and it's we
just you have to accept what it is yeah
i always say this with canon that i i
you know i get quite stressed because i
am a trekkie at heart
i mean i'm more of a gator now but i'm a
trekkie at heart um
and i it annoys me when they peel over
cannon just for the story
but then other people get
so stressed about i'm saying no
sometimes they just have to do it for
the story because well why did this
happen because they needed the story to
move along so you know so they just did
just let's calm down
um so sometimes you gotta do that i did
somebody said um it's tracky this is
because obviously with star trek they
say you've got the universal translators
and it works through the communicator so
why aren't all their mouths going like
you know and like their mouth shouldn't
move the same as the speak the language
so i mean it should be like a badly
dubbed old um you know a martial arts
movie but it's not so but stargate i
think had enough sense to just go
don't worry about it
something
we're just going to crack on it's going
to speak english because you speak
english yes because we need to so don't
worry about it don't stress it
um don't come up with some nonsense
answer that is actually doesn't make any
sense just just ignore it
but um i actually don't think in canon
there's any major problems with stargate
in star trek there's there's a few of
the things that are quite major canon
problems but
i don't think of any stargate they don't
maybe it's because they didn't go on
long enough but i don't think they got
themselves into trouble with cannon too
many times
nothing
nothing huge anyway
like them completely change in the um
the enterprise and make it 20 times
bigger than
um
it was originally or things like that um
there's a few continuity errors every
now and then but nothing yeah well
that's
nothing major
i think if you're doing 22 episodes or
whatever it is a year
and you're
and you're creating a tv show of that
quality you're allowed to make the odd
mistake
you know i i quite look like looking for
them
it's quite fun to watch like they'll
they'll they'll swipe a key card and the
the bathroom the the black bar will be
on the wrong side it's like or there'll
be a snickers bar or something like that
yeah there's a few
productions um i like there's one in
star trek actually that there's a
panning shot in dr fox's um
medical bay and somebody's left a bottle
of natural water
like you can see the logo really clearly
someone just left a bottle on the side
because i like things like that i'm
really catching a movie visiting you
don't you but
yeah ah
not me thanks for somebody okay um but
yeah so
i think the general agreement is then
yeah lately don't make it secretly
let's have the stargate everyone knows
let's crack one
um we could have starfleet um or
stargate academy
which has been sort of talked about
yeah
they kind of
started doing that didn't they
in late later seasons
they had that episode where they had to
somehow rescue jack i think
i can't remember the episode name or
what series it was in that season like
eight or nine
they kind of went started going down
that route so it makes sense that they
actually finished it
i think so and if it's going to be a
you know that we could actually have a
branch of the military there that's
stargate military space force go
um and then um you know it's like so we
can have that which could be quite thing
but all right now ian mcavoy because
you've actually watched the video i did
on this
stargate 90210 and that's a comment i
made in the video
that i don't want to see
um a stargate academy where they're a
bunch of teenagers training but i don't
think brad wright is stupid enough to do
that
and
we could see you know where it becomes
almost like um
a [ __ ]
teenage tv show rather than a sci-fi
show where he's like oh let's talk about
our emotions
that's the problem a lot of people had
with universes they bought in a
a much younger
sexier cast
which is what he said he wants to do for
this
almost those exact words how has it yeah
a younger sexier more relevant cast
don't go too young then they're not
teenagers not teenagers
yeah
we don't want to end up being like power
rangers
yeah no i don't
yeah no i don't want to see that um
somebody said sgu was 90210 i don't i
don't think that's fair but yeah it's
not far off we know we only see power
rangers either and but a um
police academy the gate is
um i would i think we can see a new sgu
team come together at the start of the
series because of something that's
happened
um
you know and
and that's how that the series kicks off
when
it's a new team and a new
uh you know thing and i i think that's
that's the
that's the way to go and people are
saying that how would like you know what
they did in the two-inch episode yeah
definitely too much episode is
i have a love-hate relationship with
that episode
i love it it's one of my favorites just
because how stupid it is
because it is stupid but i think that's
you've got to watch it for what it is
it's the 200th episode don't think of it
like a stargate episode think of it like
a special episode a celebration
of everything stargate and obviously the
producers and writers they just went
yeah go nuts
just do whatever the hell you like this
is never happened before
um you know like you know at that point
no sci-fi series had ever reached that
point
um you know 100 episodes was massive
they're in the guinness book of world
records at the time i think only two
series have done it since
um you know i think it's supernatural
i've hit 200 episodes
and something else i think they had 15
series of supernatural in the end and
there's another one as well but because
doctor who stuff doesn't count because
they're never continuous
yeah because they have massive hiatus
yeah yeah brakes but um so you know
stargate had never you know they broke
broke all the records when stark hd1 was
was there
200 episodes good or two of that but
things like the team america bits and
the puppets bits and stuff i'm like oh
that's fine it's quite difficult to
watch i like the comment about the
episode about when they went back to
1969 and basically allude to the fact
that jack is um
cam's dad
yeah
but it's never like
it's never confirmed it's just
i i like to think of it because it's the
200 episode it's a silly episode it's
just a joke
but i kind of also want it to kind of be
true
i would love that to be true i have to
admit
yeah yeah it's one of those storylines
that i did love a little they do that
quite a lot they're only little little
nods to things like that which you gotta
love but they always knew and brad
wright always knows not to go too far
yeah i think that's why i think i love
starting and i think he'll do the same
again my fear
though
is that i always felt stargate universe
was
it's not copying battlestar galactica
that's not fair
but the style
it's almost like they saw battlestar
galactica that was getting all these
pundits all going crazy for all you know
all the reviews were amazing you know
they said how beautifully made it was
everything and it
and i always felt like brad wright and
everybody else that you know cooper and
everyone else that was involved thought
let's do something a bit more serious
let's do something that actually like
like battles our galactica has done
that's you know you know a bit darker
and stuff
and it always the style is very much
like battlestar galactica to me
um i don't want brad wright to now look
at what marvel are doing and thinking
let's do something like that because i
know
or i've been told that people at amazon
do keep saying things like look what
marvel are doing look what disney doing
with this look what disney doing with
that
let's do something along those lines and
i don't want i i hope brad wright does a
stargate series
yeah i'm not sure how a marvel style
would work
um the bit i've heard about the marvel
style is is the is this thing about how
different projects would influence each
other i don't think it's actually not
like a style because actually i would
argue stargate sg-1 is
has got a sort of marvel full of feel to
it it's like action a bit of comedy
quips you can
they had intertwining episodes as well
so some of the action that's on the
events that happened in sg1 would
influence the episodes of sg atlantis
yeah and then with universe so they kind
of did already do that
yeah a little bit
i think that i like the idea of him
being like separate stories though
yeah i think yeah i think we'll see that
to a point but i think we'll
there will be
the thing that i was told is what what
they want to do is something like what
they do in mandalorian name
is that they would have multiple series
with multiple
um crews but that it's actually telling
one story you know like mandalorian goes
into boba fett which goes into the next
series of mandalorian and it's like
chapters in a book
and that would have been but even though
it's maybe different teams or different
projects they actually do follow on with
each other and it's like yeah it's like
chapters in a book but we'll see
as long as it makes sense in the
in the overall canada show
it'd be fine well the thing is with that
as well we might see
a lot more stargate that way because i
mean you know with the mandalore
whatever they're releasing the series
every couple of months
and they you know they intertwined it's
almost constant
so
you know
they will disney will get that star wars
rock and they will squeeze every last
bit of blood out of it
um until the series
i like the tv series a lot more than the
movies
since disney's had them
um yeah uh
other than solo i've quite enjoyed the
movies as well i hated solo um i didn't
watch solo
it's it's the most forgettable movie in
history
um i saw the trailer i wasn't really
i didn't like the look of it so i didn't
watch that
something happened you know i forget
what um there was probably a lightsaber
in there somewhere
um but but yeah it it's not but i mean
like rogue one was fantastic i loved
that film
and the last three movies they'd be fine
they were they're right they were
different very fish different styles but
you know but no i think mandalorian
people keep going and be
disney's ruined um star wars have ruined
and made it really woke and really think
unless i'm like watch if you watch the
mandalorian because that's brilliant
yeah
lawrence have you seen boba fett yet
yep
the best boba fett episodes are the ones
where bob fett isn't in it
um yeah
i felt like halfway through i was
watching the mandalorian
yeah i am
the the thing with the bob effect was so
off target now it's off topic
um the mandalorian was it it took you
two or three episodes to get into it i
was like this is a bit boring come on
get something happen something happen
but by the end of it you're like
can't wait for the next episode come on
something yes um yeah but it took a
little while to get into
um
yeah
so as anything else
anything else you want to see from the
new series or anything else you're
worried about with the new series
anything you don't want to see
honestly i'm just super excited for
anything
yeah any stargate any stargate
i don't know
i have fears that it's gonna be
it will end up being terrible
but
stargate is stargate i'm just super
excited
i'm eagerly waiting amazon to say
it's official here it comes
it's gonna happen i think i will cry
happy tears
i think i will lose my mind
and i'll straight on live and it'll be
probably 35 minutes of me going
i mean straight down the shop getting
the party poppers
and
you know people will be commenting
what's going on and i'll be like just
like
um
yeah no i i will i will strip live on a
on a live show when they can't when they
fight no one you don't see nobody
um
if we're going to go into rumor
what i'm told
is that they're they're in big meetings
the next couple of weeks
there might be
decisions being made
whether we'll hear about them just yet i
don't know
but
apparently the next couple of weeks are
important so
we will see what happens
um
and then
you know let's let's just
let's just hope
my only worries uh oh now somebody is
just very lovely give us a thing but
your name is the prick
thank you so much for the donation and
soda i'm gonna put it up anyway um use
rodney's wormhole drive to find destiny
why not um i don't know how they're
going to do the destiny but
thank you so much for the contribution
it really helps us out
and and that i need more contributions
so that i can quit my job and
so yeah um i felt what i was saying
because that guy's name through me
star wars really which star wars
um
yeah but i know i'm told the next couple
of weeks is really important
um and then from there
i think
a couple of things that are really
interesting happening at the moment is
you're starting to see a lot of stargate
store um
news articles and things there's one of
screen rent like a week ago
and there's one in variety magazine
talking about stargate coming back and
how it's been 20 but that might be
because of the 25th anniversary coming
up
yeah
but also the marketing people and amazon
aren't stupid and they're going to want
as much you know i think that's why this
pluto deal in america has gone through
why they allowed it to happen is because
they don't really care
because
everybody i spoke to and a lot of
company inside you know a lot of
business insiders assumed when mgm was
born that amazon would just go right
everything mgm and just go and you know
and put it onto the amazon prime and
they wouldn't let anybody else have
anything
um it doesn't look like they're going to
do that and i'm being told amazon aren't
aren't aren't going to do that they're
still going to allow mgm to operate as a
as a business
on their own sort of thing
so and they're going to be allowed to do
deals and things and amazon will act
more like a customer customer
preferential treatments i should imagine
because they're the owners
the series that the stargate series will
be available in prime though because at
the moment you have to pay for it
yeah in the uk it's on sky
um and elsewhere it's in america notes
on netflix and a couple of other places
um if you want to watch on amazon you
have to pay for it
um i i have heard rumors that they're
going to release an amazon prime as a 4k
version
um but
um
that's not confirmed that's just a rumor
but that would be that that's what i
would do
um
the 25th anniversary
so i would
um and people would go nuts you know um
i'll be straight on amazon prime as soon
as that drops if that if that drops yeah
yeah yeah
um
um but but yeah so we'll have to see
what happens with that but it's um
so that i think that's where we're at at
the moment is that the 25th anniversary
in july will be really really
interesting
i wouldn't be surprised if amazon didn't
release some sort of documentary
i you know i'd love to see that because
25 anniversary is is quite a big thing
like a making of
the
15 years that we have looking back you
know interviews with um you know rich
dean anderson and everybody and it'd be
really easy to put together they could
put it together really quickly
and if they did it in the style of that
episode with the interview that'd be
good
oh that would be great that would not be
good oh that's such a good idea
as if it's an episode
yeah yeah yeah do it that would be great
so that's the sort of thing that they
would ever do it'd be like
an interview interviewing the actor who
plays the character who's getting
interviewed about the character talking
about it
oh
twisty twisting it's like that thing
with
wormhole extreme where the guy is like
i'm playing
daniel jackson who's played by michael
shanks who was originally played by
daniel spade yeah
that'd be so good
um no but i love that yeah um yeah
exactly documentary hosted by amanda
tapping and michael shanks and they
could do some live thing on a stream
thing as well you know like like netflix
was doing after star trek came out and
they did they did a live show
immediately afterwards they could do
something like that be really cool
um
yeah yeah oh if anybody wants to come on
here
no an amazon documentary hosted by
walter
that's it you've got it
well done mate
um
but but yeah so i think we're starting
to see
these
articles and things on on on mainstream
media i think we're going to see more of
that
it won't surprise me at all if brad
wright starts going very quiet
about stargate and things as it comes
because of the um
you know as it becomes closer to reality
um
but i don't think at all this you know i
think this um script he's done it again
thank you so much again for the
contribution but
you're going to get me banned
um
so link the document jenny got killed to
make the gate public why not
and shelley i must confess i've never
watched stargate
[Laughter]
curiosity is getting to me um shelley um
runs our facebook channel and she is
amazing
um and i will be having a conversation
with her later
um
he's going to send a copy of this all to
brad right no because he he doesn't like
me very much
so broadway hates me cause i made a
mistake
um so anyway we don't need to go into
that
stress full week i had um
so that has been an amazing conversation
i think we figured out if if brad wright
hasn't got an idea on how to do stargate
just to watch this and we'll we've told
him
and guys again with your amazing
comments as always you've been really
really helpful
um is there anything you wanted to say
before we leave this lovely conversation
matthew
no thank you for having me on
yeah
we have discord
if you want to join the discord server
link for it is down below i hope if not
i will put it in the i'll put it in the
comments as well put it in the comments
it's in the description there is a link
in the description to the discord server
matt here runs our amazing discord
server he's on there constantly having
conversations
um shelley joshua johnson you have got
some catching up to do
it's uh the the server is mainly a hub
for anything sci-fi so even if you don't
like stargate
you'll like the server because there's
going to be something for everyone we're
trying to get it that way anyway yeah
there's all sorts on there but it's like
the sidetrack channel we don't we talk
about stargate a lot because it's one of
our favorite shows and hopefully it's
going to be coming back really soon but
i talk about everything as always and um
yeah i've already seen a few of your
conversations i don't get on there
enough but i will try to get on there
more i promise um but but no i thank you
so much for doing that thank you for
shelly for doing the facebook group
you're really helping us grow the
community and that's what we want
because i want to place someone with
people to come and talk about this stuff
because you know we love it
some of us love it a bit too much
i don't think you can love it too much
so most people at tim
25th anniversary will there be cake i
have to put these up because i promised
[Laughter]
i will have cake on the 25th anniversary
i will do a live video and the live
video will be just eating cake i think i
was just joined the discord server
fantastic well then
everybody else get on there immediately
right thank you so much for joining us
matt it's been an absolute pleasure
we've we've not really spoken properly
face-to-face before this which is why we
were nearly late
really pleasure i really enjoyed it
it's i i have as well mate it's been an
absolute pleasure so
thank you guys everyone's got into the
comments we are out of here as soon as i
get to the outro video which is there so
thank you very much again if you are new
to the channel like subscribe do all
that business if you want to join the
channel fantastic get on the discord
server
see
[Music]
you